[Music]
hello everybody we've got a special
guest today
ian hecox smosh here yeah working on a
new project a new game show that's very
fun yeah you posted that tell me about
it so we realized that anybody's twitter
from two or three years ago is is very
very awkward there's some things that uh
that you might have said two years ago
that maybe nowadays you could say that I
approached should have said that so we
made an entire game show around that so
we've we've taken a lot of we've invited
some of our favorite youtubers to be on
our show and then we throw their old
tweets at their faces
Gaby on October 7th 2012 you tweeted I
haven't blanked myself in a while
no retweets and like no one see it is
very funny so you posted that Smosh was
kind of moving in a different direction
and you've kind of had a big years with
Anthony leaving what is the future like
are you still gonna do sketches or is
this kind of the yeah Channel yeah we
realized that after we put the we we we
made an announcement video when we said
that we're taking Smosh in a new
direction we're making you posted that
then we realize definitely put it out
we're like oh this makes it sound like
we're only gonna do this no we're still
doing sketches but we didn't make that
clear so a lot of people I think freaked
out they're like what about the sketches
like I said and it's like no no we're
still doing that but then we're also
doing the game show so yeah we're just
trying new things so I'm gonna steal one
of your segments okay okay so we are
going to be you have to pay us for that
yeah of course of course
residual yeah um we're gonna read some
celeb tweets and we're gonna decide
whether or not they're funny oh and then
if you would like to guess who the
celebrity is go ahead and take a step
okay great mmm number one mmm does
anyone think global warming is a good
thing I love Lady gaga I think she's a
really interesting artist that's not
funny
but I would say yeah I would say I know
cher makes a lot of really incoherent
tweets something to say Oh Cher
you know what it was Britney Spears oh
yeah she makes them no yes she makes
some weird tweets - yeah
sir Graham is just it makes outside
Cowabunga dude s I'm so pumped to be on
this surfing kick
who else surfs out there gnarly day and
the h2o rotten with these are jokes they
are funny I'm just gonna have to guess
that was Cole Sprouse kim kardashian
what has she ever been on a surfboard hi
i'm in england and i pulled the fire
alarm because i thought i was flushing
the toilet Oh
again it's not a joke
nothing's pretty funny yeah who Justin
Bieber it sounds like a Bieber thing no
ain't no but Bieber wouldn't do it
accidentally he would do it
intentionally yeah he would yeah I'm
definitely little John
you know what no my mistakes that's
actually my tweet oh really yeah you do
that yeah Wow there's a week ago
[Music]
you